first of all how embarrassing it was
last night
well I would say it was a shaming
experience I mean I look at it from how
the what Britain projects to the world
and to see the government in a shambles
the mother of parliament in that chaos
what an awful spectacle that sends to
the world I mean we have a government
that's in office but not really in power
anymore you can feel Authority draining
away from them that's bad for this
country it's bad for Britain in the
world
who should accept responsibility for
what happened yesterday
well there's one person at the top of
the government whose responsibility it
is to manage the business of the
government in Parliament as well as
towards the country that's the Prime
Minister uh you know the buck stops with
the Prime Minister and she has to be
held responsible for those scenes
and what sort of response it might that
take what what might that look like do
you think
uh luckily I'm not a politician and I'm
not in the conservative party but it's
down to conservative MPS now to work out
a British prime minister with a strong
majority in the House of Commons has
enormous power but if she doesn't have a
stable majority and authority over her
and abuse and a capacity to manage her
business in the House of Commons I mean
that is a fundamentally weak situation
and we have a dangerous world out there
and people want Britain to be an active
player in you know combating Russia and
Ukraine on China and so on at the moment
we don't have a prime minister with any
Authority internationally or
domestically
how much of a problem I know you're not
a politician but you know you have been
uh within the heart of government uh
previously how much of a problem is it
when a politician who is uh who had high
office is sacked which is what happened
you know we've seen resignation letters
we know when politicians have resigned
and when they've been forced to resign
um then finds themselves on the back
benches
um I remember when
uh Mrs Thatcher did that to one of her
senior cabinet members and the
resignation speech afterwards basically
did for her
yes I think you may be thinking of
Jeffrey Howe um I am certainly it was a
pretty devastating speech yes well when
a prime minister forces out a senior
member of the government whether it's a
former Chancellor or a former Home
Secretary you know that creates someone
with a grievance against the prime
minister they may decide to settle down
and be loyal back benches or they may
not in the case of similar Braverman the
the Oddity really is that this was not a
very major
um you know misdemeanor sending an early
draft of a ministerial statement to
Parliament was not a security breach if
you like it was a parking ticket offense
rather than a dangerous driving charge
and yet she was forced out and then
Unleashed that tirade of anger against
the prime minister so it looks to me
like the Prime Minister has created
another focus of of descent on the back
benches
so it wasn't really what she did it was
because uh somebody in one of these two
offices behind me wanted her out
yeah I mean that's what it looks like it
looks to me more like a pretext either
for the prime minister to push her out
or for her to jump before she was pushed
I don't know which rather than the than
the root cause and K what I mean I'm
thinking of this morning is thank
goodness through our wonderful
professional civil service because as
the wheels come off the government we
have a civil service which is keeping
the country going day by day men and
women working extremely hard they can do
the day by day running the country they
can't make plans and policies for the
future and that's what we need
I did want to ask you about the Civil
Service as well because it is something
that you know an awful lot about
um
what's it like for them day to day at
the moment when they don't know who is
going to be the head of the ministry
they don't even know whether we're going
to have the same prime minister by the
end of the day
well it's incredibly difficult of course
because civil servants need Prime
Ministers and ministers to set the
direction to take the policy decisions
we've taken then implement but if if the
government are basically you know absent
on Parade as they run around in smaller
and smaller circles day by day civil
servants will get on with the job of
running the country of doing what is
necessary within the policy guidelines
already set they'll do that very
professionally but it is extremely
difficult to have this level of chaos
and uncertainty from one day to the next
and decisions that need to be made for
the future urgently given the economic
crisis we have will not be being made
and so they can do the day by day
management but they can't do much more
than that thank goodness they are there
to do that
are you in the business of predictions
this morning my Lord
I'm never really in the business of
predictions I mean this government
cannot last in this state I mean whether
it's days or weeks I don't know but in
the state of the world in the state of
the country the crisis we have this kind
of chaos cannot continue and it's down
to Tory MPS to sort it out but really uh
you know we've got to put an end to this
get back to some kind of stability
and and how do we do that do we have yet
another prime minister who has not been
elected uh by the country or are we
heading towards an election do you think
I mean I all I can do is speak as a you
know as an individual and actually an
individual that doesn't have a vote in
general elections because I'm a Lord but
it feels to me like just another change
of prime minister on the basis of what
conservative MPS would like there's no
longer feel very Democratic and any
sense of a democratic mandate it's
getting more and more remote so it seems
to me normally that the mother of
parliament should be setting an example
to the world and putting an end to this
kind of chaos by having a general
election
it's good to talk to you my Lord thank
you very much indeed for joining us
thank you Kate